this in-game skin made more money than a
whole game there is a mount in World of
Warcraft the sparkle pony as we call it
that was $15 I believe at the time that
mount made more money than Starcraft 2
that's right according to Jason Thor
Hall a former blizzard employee
Starcraft 2 wings of Liberty the
followup to brood war was outsold by
this the celestial Steed Mount was added
to wow in April 2010 and was the first
Mount that players could just straight
up buy from the developer so this is the
first time they've sold a mount and of
course they're selling it for 20
$5 an absurd amount of money there were
obviously sought after mounts in game
and rare loot cards for the wow TCG that
people bought with real money these days
the celestial Steed is a bit of a joke
and deservingly called the sparkle pony
this to me represents a really really
bad direction for the game and
unfortunately toal biscuit was right
that's right gentlemen a
$65 microtransaction horse